comme de copies la nièce et mirettes
arpentent les allées de cet hypermarché
ne vous y trompez pas ils ne font pas
leur compte ce sont des contrôleuse de
la répression des fraudes elles viennent
prélever des échantillons dans le cadre
du plan de contrôle à la contamination
au chlordécone mais aussi aux pesticides
reprendra ensuite des patates douces les
cristaux fut non on les prendra pour la
recherche de pesticides parce que je
vends que ces vieux cristofini constater
qu'en découvrant aussi une recherche aux
pesticides
donc ça c'est pour le chlordécone dans
leur viseur les légumes racines mais
également quelques cucurbitacées comme
le concombre et a pas de choix vraiment
donné puisque on a on a une liste de
produits à risque donc on suit leur
deuxième étape après la collecte la
traçabilité hypermarchés doit fournir
les factures des légumes vendus et qui
font l'objet du prélèvement
d'accord je suis en masso des produits
il n'y a pas qu'à la donc ces
médicaments ok si jamais un souci au
niveau du du produit sous l'abri
produits non conformes dans que nous
remontons la filière pour les
responsables de l'hypermarché ce
contrôle est nécessaire dans le but
d'une meilleure sécurité alimentaire que
les gens sont de plus en plus
concernés par ce qu'ils mangent sont de
plus en plus inquiet et et les deux
notes devant ils ne trouveront sans même
intéressant de travailler en étroite
collaboration et est spécialisée en
toute transparence a vaincu parce qu'il
faut bon
il faut qu'on soit sûr que ce conte
on vend aux clients soient de bonne
guerre une opération qui laisse
cependant certains clients dubitatif
j'ai pas confiance aux contrôles donc
bon ma foi on n'a pas le choix on
consomme
ce qui a le légume viennent de costa
rica on ne sait pas ce qu adam ou
d'année du sud c'est tout à préparer
on ne sait pas donc il faut consommer en
confort enfin troisième et dernière
étape les échantillons sont tamponnés
est scellée avant d'être envoyé au
laboratoire en guadeloupe pour analyse
il faudra attendre trois semaines pour
avoir les résultats tard en 300
prélèvements ce qui représente un
contrôle par semaine sont réalisés dans
les hypermarchés sur le bord des routes
ou encore sur les marchés de l'île